with co i guess kyle's too polarizing
kylo renounced i don't think so
personally yeah his personality is kind
of unknown it's more about the media's
portrayal i mean at the moment they're
calling for his death he just came out
and said he supports black lives matter
yeah right he also said he's he's sick
of the left and right using his case in
order to push their political agenda so
he's coming out and making a lot of
statements which uh are shocking and
surprising a lot of people including
people on the right and those statements
are the ones that actually carry weight
in court and when you get when you get
rulings that's when people start paying
attention you're never going to get his
message that of that message of saying
i'm on the left and the right or i'm in
the middle out there unless you actually
get rulings in court and that's why he's
got to bring those cases it's it's a
mistake for kyle house to come out and
say that he's supporting black lives
matter or criticizing
one side over the other probably should
just avoid the polarization
all together totally but i'll put it
this way one of the problems i see with
i guess we'd call it the right
was one of the jurors
this was going around um when asked uh
in jury selection he said he wouldn't be
a good juror he would be fair because
he's pro 2a and he supports gun rights
was that that was a that's a big thing
right and that's that right there is
like
i agree with our constitutional rights
so i shouldn't be involved in this
because only people who don't agree with
with kyle's rights should be judging him
yeah there's a there's this weird
proclivity of people who are honest to
be honest to the fault of themselves no
one is going to be able to remove every
bit of bias from from their decision
making uh anybody who goes into a jury
the person i trust lease is a person
who's like oh yeah i can ignore all of
my biases when making this jury decision
yeah everybody's got some biases the
question is can you can you reasonably
make decisions and a lot of people do
that every day um
the real issue with that is when you've
got a criminal case the person who says
oh man i i don't know if i could be
impartial in this that's the guy who's
going to be the not guilty vote right
like that's never going to be the guilty
vote if the guy's like i hate this guy
he's not going to go oh i i you know i
just can't be partial on or impartial on
this i'm going to stay on the or i need
to leave the jury no if you if you hate
the defendant then you're going to want
to be on that journey and most judges
look the the job of the prosecution
defense when you're doing jury selection
is to strike people you don't like or
you think you don't like or there's a
possibility of you not liking them what
happens though 99 of the times is you
get someone to say yeah you know what
i'm not going to be fair in this case
because of my pro-2a position the judge
jumps in and says well actually you know
remind me i'll remind you this is jury
service it's a constitutional right it
goes through a litany of legal things
and then basically asks them again are
you sure you can't set that aside we're
not asking you not to be pro 2a just
said
are you sure you can't set it aside and
be in part set it aside the judge should
say
uh just to point out the second
amendment is a constitutional right
right if you're saying that you are
opposed to constitutional rights
then perhaps i understand your argument
you're being too pragmatic
i i would be i'd be a crazy judge the
judges want see what the judges don't
want to do is dismiss everyone because
you could pretty much dismiss 95 of all
jurors in any trial at any given time if
you didn't if you didn't apply that
standard then there would be no jury
trials ever so the judge's job is to be
like we gotta really keep these people
in in the box and and despite all of the
the crap that schrader got from the
media about being oh pro you know pro
kyle or whatever in that jury selection
one of the people stood up and said i
just don't believe that anybody should
have a machine gun and the judge took
the time to say well
just so you know like there's no
allegation that anyone in this case had
a machine gun this is a semi-automatic
right and he takes this really
painstaking process to go through and
explain uh that this was not a machine
gun it's not fully automatic it's one
trigger pull one thing it's perfectly
generally legal firearm that's you know
and he did take pains to do that and and
that is someone who was likely going to
be opposed to kyle rittenhouse was that
jurors elected i don't know at the end
of the day i don't i don't remember but
it was it was early on in that jury
selection process and that was kind of a
slog i i don't i don't think i could
ever be on a grand jury or a jury i just
outright be like i am heavily biased
against the state
and there is literally nothing that's
ever going to change my mind okay i'll
tell you this they might accept your
word on that
yeah yeah we we were talking with
michael malus on the show and he was
telling the story that he it's i think
it's mostly um fictionalized for legal
purposes but he basically said to a
prosecutor in a grand jury i'm an
anarchist and i will not return an
indictment and he was like well too bad
you're on the grand jury and so he
convinced everybody to return no
indictment and the prosecutor was like
what what just happened it's like do you
let an anarchist on a grand jury they're
gonna take charge here's what we would
do with guys like that right we the
judge would call us up sidebar and be
like we're not gonna pick this guy he's
gonna be the alternate i'm gonna make
him sit here for two months
honest
if i got jury duty i'd go there and be
like i would absolutely love to be
involved in this process i love the idea
of jury duty and civic duty and i am
also heavily biased against the state
i'm just being completely honest i would
love to weigh all the evidence and if
you were fair and honest i would make a
fair and honest assessment but keep in
mind i don't trust the state do you have
a do you have a duty to inform the judge
or anyone picking you that you believe
in jury nullification that you believe
you have to tell them
if you believe in that idea
even if you're not actually sure
it's just literally illegal so like as a
defense attorney as a public defender i
wanted to argue jury nullification like
look at my poor client yeah he's just
yeah yeah yeah the state versus you know
this penniless popper you can't do that
there's crafty ways to get around that
but the other thing about jury selection
is
about 80 of your reversals come from
improper jury selection this is why
judges are so guarded against it because
they want to make sure it's the racial
thing it's called batson challenges or
whatever like you can't every every
juror has a racial profile under the law
and you can't strike one just for some
race decision and a lot of reversals
come because the defense and the
prosecution don't do enough to
to to what we call state the record of
what the case actually is and the judge
screws up and that's where a lot of
reversals come in this is the first i've
heard that
nullification is illegal what's the
history of that i thought it was totally
legal no you can't what the the premise
is you have to be able to argue the
facts that are presented in the case
right and the facts that are presented
in the case as to whatever the charge is
you can't go in there and be like uh
this guy has had the worst life in human
history this is why you should acquit
him of murder because he's just you know
has had the worst luck has been stabbed
has been you know shot at his mother
died that's why you should acquit him
you can't say that you can say you
should acquit him because he's had a
rough life but in the instance of the
murder thing he actually didn't do it
whatever what if what if it's like a
drug charge and you don't believe in the
in the law like you don't believe the
law should have been implied here
because you don't believe in victimless
crimes and and you don't think this
should be used on him so that's why you
want to nullify this by voting as a
juror and saying this this shouldn't be
applied here then then what should
happen is the the state
should be very careful in what questions
that they ask the jury on vladir
and if they don't ask you those
questions then you don't have to answer
those questions but you keep it to
yourself you don't stand up and say i
believe in jury nullification if you're
going to go nullify a jury and by the
way i fully 100 support jury
nullification this shows brought to you
by jury nullification
no uh i i 100 support it if you believe
a law is unjust and you are on a jury
for it then you have that right but you
cannot stand up and tell the judge and
the prosecutor and the defense attorney
that you're gonna do it defense
attorneys can't argue for it and uh and
if they do that's one of the the few
ways that a defense can get a mistrial
um and a redo at it so wait wait i
didn't know that what would happen if
you were on the jury like you got on
there you were selected and then when
you were walking one day said i'm going
to nullify the i'm going to i'm going to
they'll just they'll just dismiss you
yeah they'll dismiss you as a juror same
same thing they had with the guy way to
get out of it huh yeah getting out of
jury duty is really easy what you do is
you go to the bailiff and you tell a
racial joke
for those that don't know that's
actually what happened one of the
journeys yeah yeah yeah yeah i just
heard the kyle written house case but
it's also important to know that a lot
of people
who were charged under very heavily
heavy drug charges under very heavy
crimes were many times allowed to let go
because of jury nullification because
people said hey this is obscene that
this man was using this substance for
let's just say medicine but there's been
so many different cases and then the
jury said there's no way i agree with
this morally i'm gonna impose jury
nullification i don't know if they
announced it or didn't announce it but i
also heard of cases of people being
arrested outside of court courthouses
because they were advocating for jury
nullification i also saw videos about
that so is that what you meant cash by
by it being illegal or no it's act no
don't get me wrong it is illegal for a
defense attorney to go in there and
argue jury nullification it's unlocked
the defense yeah cannot do that but as a
citizen as a juror i could practice
let's live in the real world if you have
a jury and they feel bad look i would
try cases all the time and be like i
would the way you beat the cops is you
put the cops on trial and make the jury
feel worse for your client than law
enforcement you're playing to jury
nullification by trying to address facts
that show that and juries are going to
be hip to that they can make that ruling
on their own you just can't openly argue
for it you can pitch it and of course
juries do that all the time so you could
you could say something like you could
say
you know
a guy was arrested with cbd
and they're arguing it's an illegal drug
which is completely unfair here's the
facts so even though technically the
state is correct the jury's probably
gonna be like yeah but you can't tell
them that they have they could do that
exactly you can't say it and you can't
if you're you're on a pretty thin line
because a smart prosecutor will jump up
and be like that's jury nullification
and the judge will come down on you yeah
but as a citizen a lot of people don't
even know what it means a lot of people
don't even don't even understand what
jury notification is or victimless
crimes so i think you know talking about
it and spreading this kind of word
letting people know that the average
citizen if they participate in our court
proceedings have a right to throw down
unjust laws i mean that's a big power
judge a judge will tell you no that's
unlawful hillary's instruction will be
it's unlawful if they decide to do it
what are they gonna do right like how
are they gonna yeah i mean to be honest
the judge says if you believe the state
has proven you know these things about a
reasonable doubt so you can just be like
i didn't believe them yeah you didn't
meet the bar oh okay
yep and that that's the way but but it's
remember that when you're when you're
under void year you're under oath and
you are required to answer those
questions truthfully under penalty of
perjury and so you know it's really up
to the state to craft their questions to
try and eliminate things like jury
nullification and that's why um that's
that's why you saw uh in fact some of
these uh race-based dismissals uh
cropping up is because you know in
in the south for example during jim crow
you might have a white defendant and a
black victim and you would have a
jury that they would try and strike any
black jurors from that jury because they
would want a jury notification even if
the facts mixed up based on race so jury
nullification it can be used in an
inappropriate way it has in the past but
now we tend to think of it as more of a
liberty minded position attacking things
like victimless crimes and and that
frankly lies at the feet of things like
mandatory minimum sentences when when
you've got people who have like four
marijuana plants going a mandatory
minimum of 20 years in a federal prison
someone goes that's not really justified
when when joseph rosenbaum gets out and
ate yeah but people don't know this you
know they right they sit on a jury the
judge says it doesn't matter what your
opinion is the law it matters why
instruct you and they say okay
i'll lock the guy up that's what what
mal's was telling us he said you know do
you really want this kid's life to be
completely ruined do you want to be the
people you'll have this on your
conscience for the rest of your life
that you destroyed this person's life
over what a substance or something and
then people were like yeah i don't wanna
that my attitude on this is the reason
why i would almost pro like if i was on
a grand jury i'd almost never indict is
because i i'm not the judge over other
people sorry like i can i can certainly
have my opinions and be judgmental but
like to actually tell me we are going to
grant you partial power along with this
other group to condemn a person to
either
a court proceeding which is arduous and
difficult or as a jury itself to jail
prison or death i'd be like
but that's why
that's why grand juries are so big right
yeah that's why there's like you know 32
members of a grand jury the
preponderance of the evidence standard
is 51 49
not you know did he maybe do it versus
did he not do it and also you only need
like 17 of the 32 i forget the exact
breakdown so and you put me on a grand
jury over property crime or possession
or anything like that and i'm gonna be
like
thumbs down
sorry
i mean and i and obviously i'm i think
crime is bad property crime and stuff if
it's like victimless stuff like
literally someone chilling in their
house minding their own business with
some some weird thing you know that
they're not supposed to the government
says you're not allowed to have i'd be
like nah government's wrong what if
they're playing videos from facial abuse
on a big screen outside in their front
lawn what would you do then they're
doing what playing videos from facial
abuse on a big screen facial
never mind we probably shouldn't get
into it
if i'll put this away
don't worry about it but
i don't know if it was like it was like
a good esoteric joke no it's it's like a
a a violent pornographic website right
uh oh okay okay um uh
i think that's a civil issue
there you go i think i think you can
potentially argue like minor disorderly
or something or disturbing the piece
which i really am not a fan of as a law
because like dude tell me what i did
wrong cop you know like i was telling
that story the cop claimed that because
i was yelling night call 9-1-1 i was
being disordered i'm not kidding they
were like he was yelling and i was like
i was yelling call the police like
they're like we don't care so i didn't
want to do those jobs so look
you know if you've got a person who's
projecting you know really inappropriate
stuff i don't believe in obscenity laws
uh i think george crown was right when
he went out and started you know said
the seven words you can't say on tv and
if the neighbors got a problem with it i
think you've got a civil issue where the
neighbors can maybe take up some kind of
civil complaint um and maybe this is
resolved i don't think it's criminal you
know what i mean right if a guy's
putting video of himself naked out no no
no no if if somebody was projecting on
their own home
inappropriate oh i thought it was out
front in their yard yes so like on the
front of their house they're they're
showing inappropriate things like on
your garage that's what i do exposing
yourself in public no ian's right i'm
just talking about general
what's considered
you don't need to talk about and get
into specifics because we're trying to
be family friendly the point is how can
you not object to that stuff though i i
do and i think it's a civil issue not a
criminal issue i don't think the police
should come and arrest a guy because he
was making a statement
depending on who he's made when the
police are allowed to be like this is
obscene they'll say your politics are
obscene too so
if someone's like i believe in these
things and i'm gonna i think people
there's nudists this is a political view
on on clothing and the rights of
individuals and there are women who walk
around naked in new york city and are
not necessarily naked topless because in
new york city they're allowed to
so if somebody wants to make a statement
about what they deem is socially
acceptable or not and it's a public
statement i would argue it's a civil
issue and there's potentially disturbing
the peace there but i probably would not
indict there's that entire uh feminist
movement right feman uh that's what they
do they're they're topless and they
paint uh no no no no no no
sorry i dropped you oh yeah yeah you're
going well beyond them being topless
okay i haven't checked in on it lately
they they the stuff i've i was in
ukraine and the things i was told about
the stuff they do is like
hardcore overt and i can't say it wow
did you see the uh but have you ever
seen my favorite feman clip is when the
one runs at putin and he gives her the
thumbs up right before she gets tackled
i wouldn't indict
look my dad's pretty funny if it
involves kids
if someone's doing something
you know wrong with kids i'll be like
consenting adults
i contending adults can do what they
want to do man leave me out of that
business that's right if someone's
projecting it on their house and my son
is in his room looking out the window at
it i'm like well now we got a problem
and it might be criminal
no uh you go and you close his window
and say son don't look outside or if
he's sitting in the front yard you come
inside i'm why would i let him put me
out no no you can't you can't what do
you mean he put you out if he's going to
force me to hide my son indoors and bar
the windows
but that's a civil matter it's it's uh
it's a public it's a it's a nuisance uh
it's it's not a trespass because they're
not physically intruding on your
property but uh we have a whole uh tort
called uh nuisance and and it's when you
interfere with the quiet enjoyment of
someone's property that's a that's a
civil tort so that exists out there it's
it's for this exact same thing if you
have like an offensive smell uh say uh
someone buys a property next to you and
puts in a pig farm or whatever right and
then oh it happens yeah yeah yeah and
and so or or they put up bees right like
they put up bees and the bees are coming
in and stinging your kids or something
like that uh you you have uh you have
different ways to deal with this
civilian i think i i fully agree with
tim but but i would say ian like your
perspective is overtly authoritarian
well i'm talking about like porn if it's
like doesn't matter grotesque it starts
with that then where after that
well hold on
if the video is depicting illegal
activities well there's a then then i
think there's a question about what
they're showing if it's 18 and over
activities
actually that's a good point that might
be criminal
showing uh uh adult content that
requires you to be above over 18.
publicly might yeah might be crime it
could be that was the first could be
thought of yeah we were talking about
earlier so you have to have criminal you
have to have you actually the city would
actually have to have a law that states
that showing this type of stuff you know
the public display of these images is is
uh not allowed and
some of some of those get struck down as
being over broad and even if you're
prosecuted for them and they they've
been on the books you have an over
breath uh case there are federal
pornography statutes on the books that
basically say if you
if you show the wrong audience and i
forget what the wrong audience is off
the top of my head but basically kids of
a certain age
x or it's shown to x number of people
you can get into a federal crime so a
smart prosecutor would or savvy one
would be like you might just be showing
it on your house but there's probably
like a thousand people coming by seeing
it so you can basically be in what's
called the distribution business so you
get them on the uh you get them on the
violation of the broadcast rights yeah
but but a lot a lot
as a public defender i had to represent
a lot of people charged with some pretty
nasty sex crimes one of them was
dis uh distribution of pornography and
there there's not just like distribution
of pornography isn't sending someone
playboys it can happen
in a variety of ways like live audiences
just giving somebody a memory stick and
being like yeah check this in a better
example would be they were showing if
they projected a video of a cow slottery
or something
you know so you're actually seeing
videos of the cows get mounted up and
have their throat slit or whatever and
it's just you know blood spilling out
and stuff so the issue there is this is
really interesting um
when i was doing hostile environment
training they showed a video of a pig
femoral artery bleed
on purpose
a guy just flopped to the floor passed
out so um bleeds and some people trigger
a response i forgot there's a nerve
legal response what is it vagal
and so basically
out of this you know 40 people in the
room one guy saw the video and just
flopped the ground blood pressure
dropped he went unconscious
so the instructor came and lifted his
legs up to put the blood pressure back
into his head and then he immediately
tries getting up and the guy screamed at
him don't move don't get up and the guy
was like i'm fine he goes no you're not
you're only conscious because i'm
holding your legs up
but so that's an interesting question
if
that uh if it is known among these like
hostile this is these are like special
forces guys if it is known among them
that you can trigger a reaction in
people which can be serious and
medically problematic by showing a video
maybe maybe it's flashes and someone
could be epileptic now we're talking
about potential criminal intent to do
harm to others well that's uh what
happened to eichenwald right right
people were tweeting it kurt eichenwald
the uh the flashing images and uh and he
allegedly had an epileptic seizure
response to it or he's just epileptic
yeah so he said it was an attempt on my
life or something like that and they
charged the guy yeah they the the texas
court
i would say strained the uh the federal
battery statute or the yeah cause it was
a federal crime uh the federal battery
statute's on that one by saying that the
photons from the the thing hitting his
eyes because that that was intended for
those lasers where right we're actually
directing a beam into someone's eyes for
the intent of injury in my opinion but
uh yeah that that was wild also kurt
eichenwald is a weirdo
yeah
well that's that's that's him and uh for
all uh we'll just we'll leave him to his
vices i suppose him and his family
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time